how sup guys my name is Jenna welcome to
a little update video regarding a lot of
des so we're gonna talk about a lot um
there were 30 love and a number 30 which
was a last weekend not like this weekend
but the one before basically like August
22nd that weekend I did do it a live
stream the whole thing on twitch.tv
falls - the channel was great I had all
the fun and I'm gonna talk a bit about
the game I made and a bit about my
general experience with it and what I
was going for and you know all that kind
of good stuff this is gonna be sort of
like a reflection video but it's also
kind of hoping also gonna be talking a
lot about like the experience I had and
technology I used them or not so that
being said what was I gonna start off
with I was gonna start off with by
saying that the game I made was called
evacuate it you can play it there's a
link in the description below that will
take you to the lunder page for my game
okay so there you'll see the links you
need to play the game alright as well as
the source code which I still haven't
uploaded but I will so by the time you
see this video I think I'll have this
all straight out okay can't guarantee
that but probably okay so just they'll
probably be both links there if they're
not just wait like a day or so but they
should be there okay that being said
what is evacuate and what more my girls
fall items there now every time I do
Laden dare I first of all the theme was
connected worlds okay this time around
the thing was connected worlds I didn't
like that theme the first time I heard
it but okay it kind of grew on me and I
guess I kind of did something similar to
that at least that being said though I
really need to write a story for this
properly but my goals for any Laden dare
and I've said this numerous times before
but my goal for pretty much every time I
do item dare is to learn something new
every time okay I'm kind of making games
is all cool and well and I and I do that
a lot
but like outside of these competitions
and whatnot but I really value the
experience of creating something new and
it's something like a 48 hour game
programming competition on game
development competition yeah you know
like a lot um there the thing about such
competitions is that it gives you an
awesome opportunity to actually you know
devote 48 hours or in my case like 20
hours because I like slow
so much but to devote that kind of time
into into making something and if you do
take on a new technology you'll pretty
much learn that ok so I remember once
you know for the very first time I use I
did love him day I made a really good
guarantee I still think that is my best
game called Genesis that I need to find
that game I honestly can't find that
game I need to upload that and its
source code to like get help or
something but I don't know where it is
right now but anyway the first time I
did it I kind of used something on you
but I wasn't I wasn't that good of a
program of course I was like in always
2012 so two years ago basically exactly
nailed my first love until under 24 but
pretty much since then I've kind of
started learning new stuff so for
example in let him in in the next 11
charity which I think was 26 I made
squared right the first day of that and
for the for those of you who saw life
frame would have known that for the
first day of that you know I tried to
basically learn the whole object input
output stream in Java okay for
multiplayer and I didn't know that at
all and that didn't really work out very
well but since then you know for example
legacy OpenGL was the next game then
like modern OpenGL with shaders was like
the the the game after that and whatnot
and I've always been only these new
technologies but this time I just went
like I didn't even use Java this time
this is the first time I have not used
Java this is a full web game okay it is
completely WebGL basically okay so
before let him dare 30 right I basically
like JavaScript is what I used to write
this game I probably I'd never written a
single class in JavaScript so I've never
done any kind of object-oriented
JavaScript before now the JavaScript
really has massive support for that but
um my extent of JavaScript was probably
like a function here and there that's it
just a function that probably you know
sets I don't know if sets some HTML
elements to be something and or maybe
like makes something happen when you
click on a button that's it like I have
quite a lot of PHP experience but not
JavaScript JavaScript like no experience
I went into this and I obviously made
this in JavaScript right so I basically
learned JavaScript
I use an engine called 3j s alright
really good engine
it's more of like a framework for WebGL
that kind of makes it kind of makes like
your life easier so I did I use that and
I know the videos like ended here but
just it doesn't matter so I use that and
and I ended up making a game that you
know although isn't 100% finished it's
still playable you know it's still it's
still out there it's it's not it's not a
complete disaster but um you know III
did definitely learn a lot right and
that again that's my goal every time I
did a lot of death so in my eyes it was
a complete success the game itself is
quite boring I'm not gonna lie I'm over
say it's a it's a good game but it is
playable it looks pretty nice and if you
actually look really close so you can
see the clouds actually move at
different speeds to the to the earth
rotating which i think is really cool
but anyway the point is that it was a
good experience for me right and that's
what I like about lot um dan that's what
you guys should do as well right
I know a lot of you were really scared
to do love them day I don't know why
like you probably know as much about
your technology as I do about mine when
I jump into lot of dead because again I
used something new every time I might
not do that next time because still I do
want to make a really good game at some
point during item there but that being
said that's what your preliminary goal
should be okay at least if you're not
even in it to make an awesome game just
learn something that's probably one of
the one of the most valuable lessons I
can give all right so that's my love
them day that's what I did lot in there
I learned a new technology JavaScript
and WebGL basically and yeah sorry next
time though December I'm probably gonna
be used the Cherno mentioned so if you
guys don't know on github.com for / - oh
no
there is a little git repository called
shadow engine okay it was actually just
called China okay that's my love and
dare engine but I'm actually finish I
thought about in like March or something
but um and I did laughs turned out a lot
but what I want to do hopefully over the
next few weeks wants my internet at home
gets fixed because it's currently down
I'm going to hopefully do some live
streams on YouTube
okay not on twitch because twitch has
lost its little copyright he can you can
play copyrighted music things and then
the video and demands don't get me to
think it's lost the you can play
whatever music you like things so I'm
gonna try and stream on YouTube again
we're gonna see how that works out but
hopefully we're gonna do some sweet
Cherno engine development in the coming
weeks flappy bird should be continuing
as well of course as well as game
programming whenever I have time but the
deal is for next Island air hopefully
I'm actually gonna use the channel
engine and something like Java but the
point is I just wanted to reiterate that
my goal was to learn something new I did
learn something new and that's fantastic
I'm also going to upload a time-lapse of
the whole development process of this
game evacuate soon okay maybe tomorrow
all right
so I'll see you guys soon goodbye